[Música]
a ver si os pido que me diréis el nombre
de una potencia emergente estoy
convencido de cuál sería vuestra primera
respuesta en la mayoría de los casos la
república popular china ahora bien según
como la formulamos la pregunta tiene
matices potencias exactamente en que si
hablamos de potencia industrial y
exportadora no hay dudas potencia
demográfica obviamente potencia
económica nada despreciable pero y
potencia militar pues queridos amigos
amigas es esta última cuestión la que va
a acaparar hoy toda nuestra atención
como está siendo la evolución militar
del gigante asiático podemos hablar ya
de una incipiente globalización armada
de china como rankea en relación a los
eeuu de américa pues fijaos por ejemplo
en este gráfico
[Música]
el presupuesto militar base de eeuu fue
de 778 mil millones de dólares en 2020
mientras que el gasto de china apenas
superó los 250 mil millones es decir que
hoy por hoy el 'tío sam' más que
triplica el esfuerzo en el gasto militar
del país de los tres reinos claro que
tampoco resulta extraño y el presupuesto
militar de eeuu es tan grande que supera
los de china india rusia reino unido
arabia saudita alemania francia japón
corea del sur italia y australia juntos
es el presupuesto militar de toda una
enorme fuerza global así que con los
números en la mano y teniendo en cuenta
la enorme diferencia que aún lo separan
parece difícil que china terminó
alcanzando a eeuu en materia de
presupuesto militar durante al menos las
próximas dos décadas ahora bien un
momento realmente es esto importante
para el gigante asiático realmente le
hace falta para poder rivalizar con el
gigante norteamericano pues atentos
[Aplausos]
[Música]
durante los últimos 30 años china ha
cambiado mucho y la cuestión es que su
forma de entender el ejército o la
defensa nacional y sobre todo la
política exterior también han
experimentado todo una enorme revolución
una revolución que podemos dividir en
tres fases muy pero que muy diferentes
entre sí
[Música]
la primera fase correspondió la
estrategia de la defensa mediante la
guerra prolongada a gran escala de mao
zedong su base esencial era disponer de
un ejército enorme gigantesco aunque
fuera rudimentario y estuviera mal
equipado llegado el caso este plan previ
e incluso movilizar a los propios
ciudadanos cuando fuera necesario aunque
no contarán con entrenamiento ni
equipamiento específico luego la segunda
fase fue la conocida como estrategia de
los 24 caracteres fue impulsada por deng
xiaoping y pasaba por mantener un perfil
exterior y militar bajo para favorecer
el desarrollo económico y no ser visto
por el resto del mundo como una amenaza
esta estrategia se mantuvo intacta
durante la presidencia de iu en chemin
aunque empezó a cambiar durante la era
de hu jintao cuando dio comienzo la gran
modernización militar y por último la
tercera fase corresponde a la idea del
regreso del reino del centro una
estrategia impulsada por xi jinping
mediante el llamado rejuvenecimiento
nacional y que implica colocar de nuevo
a china como eje vertebrador de la vida
política de asia para ello el dictador
chino ha ordenado expresamente convertir
al ejército popular de liberación en una
fuerza militar de primer orden para 2000
y ojo porque la idea de xi jinping no
solo pasa por tener un ejército de
primer nivel que sirva para defender a
china sino utilizarlo también para
expandir su área de influencia política
y amigos no penséis ni por un instante
que todo esto no es más que mera
retórica o meras tribulaciones los
discursos y sobre todo las acciones del
líder chino no dejan lugar a la duda
mientras ponemos un esfuerzo consciente
en aprender de la historia para crear un
futuro brillante debemos acelerar la
modernización de la defensa nacional un
país fuerte debe tener un ejército
fuerte en una lucha heroica y tenaz el
partido comunista chino y el pueblo
chino declaran solemnemente al mundo que
la nación china da la bienvenida al
advenimiento de un gran salto del
ascenso a la prosperidad modesta y la
fuerza naciente la nación china ha
entrado en un proceso histórico
irreversible xi jinping presidente de la
república popular china toda una
declaración de intenciones ahora bien
como se ha llegado hasta aquí y la
pregunta del millón tuvieron acaso las
políticas de apertura y desarrollo de
china y el objetivo claro y
predeterminado de convertir al país de
nuevo en la potencia hegemónica del
continente asiático es algo que se está
produciendo por la propia evolución de
los acontecimientos
sea como sea el caso es que fue el
presidente hu jintao el antecesor de xi
jinping que gobernó china entre los años
2003 y 2013 quien empezó a romper con la
visión no intervencionista de xiaoping
fijaos debemos conceder gran importancia
a la seguridad marítima espacial y ciber
espacial debemos hacer una planificación
activa para el uso de fuerzas militares
en tiempos de paz expandir e
intensificar la preparación militar y
mejorar la capacidad para realizar
muchos tipos de tareas militares la más
importante de las cuales es ganar la
guerra local en la era de la información
hu jintao ex presidente de la república
popular china si lo habéis escuchado
bien al contrario de lo que muchos
piensan fueguinos y quien arrancó la
escalada militar china aunque claro el
actual líder ha llevado las cosas mucho
pero que mucho más lejos sólo tenemos
que pensar en hong kong o en las
constantes provocaciones a taiwán casi
que se podría decir que la diferencia
entre hu jintao y xi jinping es la que
hay entre serlo y creérselo quería serlo
y si quiere creérselo
[Música]
hu jintao puso en marcha una fuerte y
rápida modernización del ejército
popular de liberación por ejemplo
durante su presidencia se cuadriplicó el
presupuesto militar en términos
absolutos se superó por primera vez la
barrera de los 150 mil millones anuales
de gasto en defensa y en sus tres
últimos años de gobierno 80 aumentó el
presupuesto militar a un ritmo de entre
el 13 y el 18 por ciento interanual
gracias a esto en la era tinta china
comenzó a operar su primer portaaviones
lanzó las dos primeras versiones de
bombarderos furtivos y desarrolló toda
una nueva gama de misiles balísticos uno
de ellos por cierto de carácter
intercontinental con hasta 14 mil
kilómetros de rango y es que el 11 en 41
es capaz de alcanzar la mayor parte del
planeta durante los últimos años de hu
jintao se sentaron las bases para que
luego xi jinping te empiezas a imponer
en asia especialmente en taiwán y en el
mar de la china meridional una
superioridad militar más activa es decir
los chinos ya no sólo tienen las armas
ahora también las pasean para
demostrarle a sus vecinos quien tiene el
poder
es decir que lo que hizo xi jinping fue
heredar y profundizar una carrera
armamentística que ya había comenzado
pero con un objetivo más rimbombante
reconstruir la grandeza de china
especialmente de puertas por fuera claro
que para lograr este objetivo
xi jinping no sólo necesita un ejército
más moderno necesita sobre todo estar
como mínimo a la altura de eeuu en asia
y la pregunta amigos es que parte de
este ambicioso objetivo se ha logrado
pues bien veámoslo
[Música]
el regreso del reino del centro
i
aunque pueda sorprendernos y aunque
pueda parecer mentira si ya hay cosas en
las que el ejército chino del 2021 ha
adelantado al mismísimo ejército de los
eeuu el ejército más poderoso de toda la
historia de la humanidad concretamente
podemos hablar de tres campos
[Música]
en primer lugar china tiene mayor
capacidad de construcción naval lo que
ha hecho que la armada de este país se
convierta ya en la más grande del
planeta tecnológicamente y en términos
de tonelaje a aún está muy lejos de eeuu
pero su evolución y su creciente
capacidad la convierten ya en un enemigo
difícil de batir en un conflicto
regional en segundo lugar están los
misiles balísticos y de crucero con base
en tierra el ejército chino tiene ya más
de 1250 misiles balísticos listos para
ser usados en un conflicto regional y
por último china cuenta con el mejor
sistema de defensa aérea del mundo
gracias a los sistemas rusos s-300 jesse
400 junto a otros sistemas autóctonos
los cielos de chinas son quizás los más
fortificados del mundo
claro que de momento y esto es muy pero
que muy importante hablamos de
capacidades regionales
[Música]
me explico muchas veces en los medios de
comunicación nos encontramos con
noticias y reportajes que nos describen
a china en términos de competencia
directa con eeuu en el terreno militar
pero eso no es estrictamente cierto los
líderes chinos son conscientes de que
hoy por hoy las distancias siguen siendo
siderales por ejemplo mientras que china
sólo tiene dos portaaviones activos y un
tercero en proceso de ser completado
para 2023 eeuu tiene 20 portaaviones en
servicio precisamente por eso el
objetivo inmediato de china no pasa por
convertirse en una superpotencia mundial
sino sobre todo en una superpotencia
regional es decir para entendernos lo
que busca el gobierno de xi jinping es
dominar el nuevo corazón económico del
mundo y amigos sabéis que ahí si las
cosas están mucho pero que mucho más
igualadas y muy pronto china podría
superar las capacidades de eeuu y muy
importante para lograrlo necesita mucho
menos recursos que el hegemón
norteamericano pensando en un momento
mientras que eeuu tiene un inmenso
océano de por medio aquí por tanto por
ejemplo necesita una gran flota de
portaaviones equipos de despliegue y
bases militares repartidas por todo el
mundo la situación del gigante asiático
es totalmente diferente
[Aplausos]
al gobierno chino le basta con tener
unas fuerzas armadas modernas capaces de
hacer frente a lo que eeuu tiene
desplegado en sus bases de asia-pacífico
una región donde la potencia
norteamericana tiene desplegados unos
325 mil soldados 180 buques alrededor
del 60% de toda la armada estadounidense
y unos 1500 aviones pues bien para
lograr su objetivo a china le basta con
superar las capacidades norteamericanas
en la región y eso es exactamente lo que
están persiguiendo limitarse a su
vecindario más próximo en el resto del
mundo en cambio china sigue una
estrategia de influencia alejada
completamente de la esfera militar se
dedican a invertir comprar empresas dar
préstamos a países en vías de desarrollo
y construir infraestructuras una
estrategia que quizás puede dar muchos
frutos durante las próximas décadas pero
que hoy por hoy no tiene ambición
militar alguna
claro que no hace ninguna falta el mundo
amigos ha cambiado y hoy controlar
asia-pacífico basta para condicionar
toda la política mundial y eso eso es
precisamente lo que explica que a la
hora de la verdad la diferencia de
presupuesto militar entre eeuu y china
puede no ser tan importante además los
chinos cuentan en cierto modo con otra
ventaja la etérea frontera entre la
economía civil y el campo militar
[Música]
[Aplausos]
desde la llegada al poder de si se
incorporaron requisitos militares a la
infraestructura civil y se aprovechó la
construcción civil para fines militares
también se han aprovechado capacidades
logísticas y de servicios civiles para
reforzar la capacidad de las fuerzas
armadas al tiempo que se ha profundizado
y expandido el sistema de movilización
de defensa nacional que tiene como
objetivo contar con todos los recursos
nacionales para su uso en la carrera
militar china y eventualmente en una
guerra todo esto que os estamos contando
tiene nombre y apellidos la estrategia
de desarrollo de fusión militar civil
también conocida como mc efe por sus
siglas en inglés
[Música]
para que os hagáis una idea la base
industrial de defensa china no estuvo
tan fusionada con la industria y la
tecnología civil desde por lo menos la
época de mons y tournai y que quiere
decir todo esto pues básicamente que el
gobierno chino quiere aplicar al campo
militar toda la evolución tecnológica y
operativa de las empresas chinas
es decir en otras palabras el gobierno
chino quiere convertir al país en todo
un fortín y en una fuerza imbatible en
asia-pacífico para lograr lo siguiente
está dispuesto a utilizar todos los
recursos que sean necesarios incluyendo
los recursos de las empresas privadas
chinas y eso eso también significa que
en cierto modo el presupuesto militar
pues puede no estar reflejando todo el
esfuerzo que china realmente está
haciendo en el terreno militar vale pero
queréis un ejemplo concreto pues ahí
tenemos el caso del conocido como collar
de perlas chino un megaproyecto que
consiste en el desarrollo de bases
puertos y estructuras navales de todo
tipo bajo control de empresas chinas que
van desde el mar de la china oriental
hasta el mismísimo mar mediterráneo la
cuestión es que en principio la red
tiene un enfoque civil pero no nos
engañemos es muy probable que muchos de
esos nodos tengan también un potencial
uso militar desde luego los analistas
militares es algo que dan por hecho es
decir en otras palabras que la carrera
entre eeuu y china la carrera de verdad
la carrera que importa puede estar mucho
más igualada de lo que podríamos pensar
en un principio
sí a ver la superioridad económica
tecnológica y militar de los eeuu sobre
china sigue siendo gigantesca pero a
pesar de ello ya no está del todo claro
que la potencia norteamericana pudiera
superar fácilmente a china en asia
pacifico el nuevo corazón económico
industrial del mundo está amigos es la
globalización armada con la que sueña
sigue en pie ni el partido comunista
chino controlar la joya de la corona
para influir en todo el mundo y más
importante ahí es amigos donde siempre
parece estar saliéndose con la suya y es
exactamente ahí donde se sitúa la nueva
prioridad de los eeuu de américa pero
llegamos hasta aquí turno para ti cómo
crees que eeuu y en general los países
occidentales pueden contener el
creciente liderazgo de china en la
región más importante del planeta
déjanos por aquí abajo tus respuestas y
ahora si este vídeo te resultó
interesante no olvides darle a like y
suscribirte a visar politics si es que
aún no lo has hecho una vez más muchas
gracias por estar ahí un saludo y hasta
la próxima
[Música]